is one of france's best-known
politicians a fiery orator and former
trotskyist the far-left party leader has
spent years on the margins of french
politics but melanchol's fortunes are
changing opinion polls suggest he could
make it to the second round of the
presidential election at a rally in
lille he said if elected he'd end in
equality fight climate change and tackle
the cost of living crisis
of french people are being strangled by
the rising cost of living and fuel
prices millions of french people so the
role of those who lead the nation is to
fix this
milongshan supporters say he's the
antithesis of emmanuel macron who
melonchon once nicknamed the president
of the rich
it's been a difficult five years for
many people so as far as i'm concerned
we can't re-elect emmanuel macron
embodies anti-capitalism pro-workers
rights we're sick of factories shutting
in france we want a strong europe and
melon shawn's the only one with answers
one of the main reasons that milan is
doing so well in this presidential
election is because france's traditional
left-wing socialist party is doing badly
for decades the socialist party was a
political force that created presidents
but the arrival of the centrist macro in
2017 and a shift among voters to the
political right has left the socialist
party in tatters and its presidential
candidate and idalgo floundering in the
polls the socialist party still has
local
mayors but on the national level it has
lost any appeal because it's lost
a program it's lost ideas it lost the
battle of ideas and and francois
hollande's presidency is seen
in its legacy as a moment of weakness
in terms of ideas in terms of proposals
in terms of also answers to the problems
of globalization of
the changes
in the society
with most parties on the left including
the greens trailing in the polls
milongsha is expected to reap the
majority of left-wing votes few people
expect him to win the presidency but
making it past the first round could
signal that france's left is ready for a
revival natasha butler al jazeera lil